well it's hard for most of us to imagine
what it must be like to be brett
kavanaugh right now but david
sorensen has some idea he once worked as
a white house speech writer he was fired
after the washington post published an
article accusing him of domestic
violence
without a conviction or solid evidence
around and without much time to respond
to the charges
he lost his job and his reputation was
destroyed
if current trends continue a lot of
people might learn what that's like
david sorensen joins us tonight to tell
us david thanks a lot for coming on
thanks for having me tucker so i'll just
say up front i mean i know nothing about
your marriage
or the details even of this case all i
know is
that you did not have a chance to
respond there didn't seem to be concrete
evidence these charges were
true they were made by someone who had
i think motive to make them and
the consequences you suffered were
overwhelming what was your response to
this
well i felt a deep um and profound
frustration i think that judge kavanaugh
is feeling that right now
as we speak probably uh that i never
thought i'd feel in my life and
the feeling of having a reputation that
you've that you've so carefully built
over so many years be destroyed in an
instant
and furthermore for millions of people
to believe
these baseless accusations simply
because they fit a
political narrative is incredibly
frustrating and i couldn't imagine
um you know how difficult it must be
actually well i could for
for judge kavanaugh and the situation
he's in right now it's terrible
what i found is something that's
you can't get back well i find so
striking so there are lots of crimes
committed in this country all the time
and in almost
all of them we wait to hear the evidence
then we weigh it to decide what we think
of it but in this one specific category
of alleged crime we weighed it
dramatically to one side
so did you feel like you had the onus
of proving that you weren't a domestic
abuser did you feel like people just
automatically believed your ex-wife
yes absolutely even though there was no
evidence whatsoever it was
simply a a baseless allegation
it contradicts everything we've learned
throughout our lives about justice about
fairness it contradicts the legal system
that we've built up carefully over
centuries
to create a fair forum for getting to
the bottom of the truth
and it's it's really scary how the left
is waging a war on the basic
um building blocks of our civilization
when it comes to
priorities like truth fairness merit
reason these are things that are thrown
right out the window
at the expense of their their pursuit of
political power
and it's also equally shameful to see
the media just participate in it so
so egregiously um when they used to be
considered or ideally they were
considered to be sort of an
arbiter of truth or an institution in
our society that was designed to uncover
the truth and now they're participating
in these reprehensible smear jobs
yeah well they're a herd of craving dumb
people it's just such a sad
and ominous trend for those of us who
have sons
it is terrible and your reputation is
something that's
gained by the raindrop and lost by the
bucket full
and judge kavanaugh is learning that the
hard way and i hope that we're calling
him justice kavanaugh despite it all
very soon
david sorensen thank you very much for
that i appreciate it